so hello it's a great pleasure today
uh to talk about congenital cmv
although there's a little bit of sadness
associated with that in that
we still see in my country australia
about one baby born every day with
severe malformation due to congenital
cmb
and in countries like the us with much
larger populations
we may see 10 or 15 babies born every
day
with problems due to congenital cmv
however the really positive thing is
that
a lot of steps have been taken by groups
both nationally and internationally to
stop cmv and this
in the bottom left of your screen was a
campaign a few years ago that came out
of the us
where we all wrote stop cnv and
put our hands up the bottom right is our
the research team that i work with
here in sydney in australia
and the other photo is of a meeting we
had a couple of years ago when we came
up with consensus recommendations
i think it's really important that we
look at
not only where we are now and what we
can do now
but also what we can do in the future
so just to put in perspective who i am
i'm the director of what's called the
serology and virology division which is
a
diagnostic division we call savad
that's here in sydney and we do a lot of
work on congenital infections we have a
a clinic we have a
a role nationally and and statewide in
reference testing we do some whole
genome sequencing
not only as part of testing but also as
research
and more recently i guess along with a
lot of maternity feta medicine people
a lot of midwives a range of policy
makers a range of
non-government organizations including
the cerebral palsy association cpa
as well as the congenital cmv
association of australia
we've done a lot of work around
engagement and education
so i guess that's what i mean by there
are a lot of things we can do now
on the left of your screen is some of my
research interests our group here works
particularly on how virus gets
from the mother to the baby and we're
quite interested in how we might
be able to uh reduce that um
and we i'll show you a little bit of
research although really
today is more about diagnosis and and
clinical
and other aspects of
cmv so here's the outline of
my talk the reality is
that we have a lot of
clinical issues to do we have a lot of
clinical issues to deal with daily
and we have a lot of work to do in
diagnosis
in prevention and using what we know
in going forward so i thought i'd start
just with the clinical issues talk a
little bit about the epidemiology
by nature this is going to be really
about
australia although in many ways
developed countries have a very similar
epidemiology of congenital cnb
developing countries have quite a
different uh
epidemiology because in developing
countries the zero positivity rate is
much higher
and so the predominant nature of
infection
is reactivation so um
uh here's a photo of thomas weller who
um received the nobel prize he
um he described um culture of cnb
um and uh the
this this photo i think was taken about
1955
um 70 years on
and we still have congenital cmv as the
most common infectious cause of
congenital malformation in developed
countries
uh i think that's really an important
statement to make up front
and to think about uh if we were having
the same talk
say 50 years ago maybe 60 years ago
we'd be talking about rubella and of
course probella vaccination
in developed countries and again in
australia to give the example
we don't have congenital rubella there
may be one case every
three to five years uh sadly but that
one case is typically an unvaccinated
person
and usually a person from overseas
rubella in adults still does occur but
the reality is
that rubella vaccination has effectively
eliminated congenital rubella syndrome
so that gives me a lot of hope that when
we say congenital cmv is now most common
and it's the second most common overall
only second to cerebral palsy
that we can do something with things
like vaccines and improved treatments
and improved approaches
that in going forward we can see the
disappearance of
congenital cmv as a major cause of
malformation
and make this talk hopefully redundant
in the same way that
a talk in australia about about rubella
is largely
historical interest just to put it in
perspective
cmv the most common infectious cause of
disabilities much more common than down
syndrome
much more common than spina bifida and
logarithmically more common than that
any other infection in this country
infections such as toxoplasmosis are
rare congenital
disease due to herpes simplex or
varicella zoster are vanishing
fortunately
vanishingly rare
so when you think about congenital cmv
of course one of the rather confusing
things is
firstly we don't have a vaccine and why
don't we have a vaccine we'll talk a
little bit about that later
but in essence i think it's because
we need more resources put into
development of a cnv vaccine
and that may be coming along in the next
five years
there are some candidates but secondly
one of the other confusing things is
that in fact
when infection occurs in the mother and
transmission occurs from mother to baby
most of those babies about um eight out
of ten
uh are normal and unaffected now
in obstetric terms of course uh two out
of ten is actually a very high level of
disease or disorder in an infant
but the reality is that there is
something
that means that some babies are being
infected but also developing disease
whereas other babies become infected but
don't develop disease
and so one of the aspects of research of
course is to find out what's the
difference between those two groups
congenital cmv disease typically causes
sensory neural deafness that's the most
common outcome
that can be mild all the way too
profound and it can
get worse over over an infant's life
over the first
up to five years uh vision loss and
intellectual impairment of course are
really very feared complications and
as part of the neurological disease uh
cerebral palsy as well as things such as
seizures can occur
most severely the infant can die
and i'll talk to you a little bit in a
minute about stillbirth because
we and others have become interested in
whether stillbirth could be due to cmv
and the short answer is some cases are
just looking again to put this in
perspective
one of the things that strikes me when
i'm in clinic and and talking to mothers
and fathers about congenital cmv
whether they're at risk or whether
they've had an affected baby or whether
they
have evidence of infection and they're
wondering uh what they will do with
their pregnancy and how whether
they will continue or whether they would
look at some experimental treatments
one of the things that i'm typically
told is
why didn't i hear about this why didn't
i hear from our obstetrician why didn't
i hear from my primary care physician
why didn't my i hear from my
midwives why didn't i hear a child care
all those things
and and one of the things that strikes
people
is this kind of graph cmv is
logarithmically more common than any
other infection
they know about the stereosis soft
cheese they know about toxo
cats and raw meat
they know about avoiding these things
they know about vaccination they've been
vaccinated for rubella and the reality
is
that parents can become very angry
that they haven't been told about cmv
when i tell them
that the most common infection
is cnb and congenital cmv
so what are the numbers uh approximately
um one percent over all of um
uh women who who become pregnant have a
primary or first seeing the infection
there was a systematic review that
showed this is 0.64
about a third of those transmit across
the placenta of the fetus so
cmv transmission to the infant is almost
universally
by the placenta although uh on occasion
you can get postnatal cmv
because cnb is excreted in the
cervix and of those that transmit about
one or third are symptomatic at birth
and
one third have later secretly so
particularly sensory neural hearing loss
and that occurs up to the age of five
years
this is from a paper by mike cannon that
we participated in and published a few
years ago
looking australia england and wales
and the us and just showing the rough
population at that time
in australia just to give our figures
about 300 000 live births
if you use 0.6 which is as i say a
fairly
conservative figure for congenital cv
infection
that's about 1800 and if you look at
those who are symptomatic at birth and
subsequently asymptomatic at birth but
develop disease
you come up in australia with a number
around about
three to four hundred congenital cmb
cases a year
that is about one a day of infants who
have
moderate to severe disease if you look
at
england and wales that's about 800 a
year
and the us about four to five thousand a
year
so proportionate to the population
the issue around screening is a vexed
one
and um again when parents say well i
didn't know about this but
why wasn't i screened i'm screened for
hiv i have screening
testing for hepatitis c i have screening
testing for syphilis
i have screening testing sometimes for
group b streptococcus
all of these things are reasonable in a
uh a population
where we have the resources to do this
where we can eliminate and do some
things about these infections why aren't
i screened for cmv
well it's a difficult and complex
question that we'll talk about but at
the moment the recommendation is
screening for cmv is not a good idea
although i think that will change over
the coming years
as we develop better treatments as
vaccination comes
on board and as we realize that
we can prevent um these infants from
developing severe disease due to
congenital scene b
but this just puts it in context we now
screen
for hearing disorders routinely in
australia and in many developed
countries
we screen for things like amino acid
disorders and
a number of hemoglobin globinopathies
there's nothing wrong with that but the
point is
that these are many fold lower than
congenital cmv disabilities
so these other conditions are important
there's no doubt about that
we screen for them and yet cmv which is
far more common
we don't screen for
so what are the sort of risks the other
thing that happens in my clinic
is that the typical mother who is at
risk has
often a first child may be seen be
sero-negative but then acquires
infection and risk of infection
particularly when that child is um in
uh child care and this is a paper we
published a couple of years ago there
are similar papers from europe and the
the us as well as some asian countries
japan
um and this basically looks at the the
odds ratio
from a number of studies where uh the
risk
of um cmv
acquisition in day care centers or dccs
was examined compared to controls and
basically if you're in a daycare center
that child has a high risk of acquiring
cmv
usually in these infants they're
asymptomatic and usually there's no
problem
however the risk of course is they
transmit to their
mother who is pregnant and sero-negative
at that time
so i've talked a bit about the clinical
effects of congenital cmv
particularly about sensorineural hearing
loss this is a list of the other things
clearly the most feared are the severe
intellectual
impairment and microcephaly as well as
death of the infant from overwhelming
infections but things like
hepatosplenomegaly
jaundice premature birth are very
important causes of ongoing disease
i mentioned since when you're a hearing
loss and this is from a paper
again a few years ago looking at
all causes of hearing loss so the
etiology in a
an infant population who are being
screened for hearing loss
and cmv was congenital cmv was present
in about eight percent
we have a national uh pediatric
surveillance study the australian
pediatric surveillance unit or apsu
study
which has been looking at congenital cmv
amongst
a diagnosis amongst pediatricians for
over 20 years
and if you look at the highlighted on
the left of your screen
sensorineural hearing loss is found uh
in about
10 to 20 percent depending upon
when the infection was diagnosed
congenital cmb is properly diagnosed
before three weeks of age
although probable cases are diagnosed
after that
so clearly sensory neurohearing loss is
important
there have been a number of studies
including one from us in australia
that we published a couple of years ago
where we found rates
of around six percent of um
congenital cmv in hearing loss which had
been identified
with universal newborn hearing screening
and that's similar to papers from the
u.s
uh papers from the netherlands papers
from the uk
where levels of around five to ten
percent
um have been found so once new
universal newborn hearing screening
became available
it became logical to test any of those
children who were failing
hearing screening that is who had
sensory neuro hearing loss
to test them for congenital cmv
this led to questions about whether uh
with
universal newborn hearing screening
should all those
infants who are tested have um
congenital cnb
testing which is simply a salivary swab
or a urine swab
tested using typically a
polymerase chain reaction or pcr or
other molecular test
specific for cnb and if it was positive
and particularly positive within the
first three weeks of life
then appropriate interventions for
congenital cnv could be undertaken
that that was a theoretical paper that
we published with mike cannon about five
years six years ago
and then we also looked at whether some
of the treatments
were a benefit in fact there are some
treatments that now
have a marginal benefit and what we hope
is in going forward we could find
benefits that
were much larger and would make
treatment more effective
three years ago we published um this
paper down the bottom left of your
screen where
we looked at consensus recommendations
because a number of us
internationally felt that there are
enough data to start
telling us what we should be doing and
providing better evidence-based
recommendations
for things like diagnosis uh and
and to inform i guess governments in a
scientific and evidence-based way about
whether they should be doing
universal screening uh for cnb and
mothers
whether they should be doing universal
screening for congenital seeing the
in infants and really to assist with
that decision-making
and so these recommendations which were
written uh
published three years ago but written of
course about four years ago
we hope to update and there's a meeting
next year when
people gather internationally to look at
this there are also recommendations
published around the same time from
europe although they particularly
address
treatment and so what a number of us to
have done and this is an example
from here in australia is look at
what we can do now and how we can better
inform parents and this is one example
one of the things that that struck us
early on was that cmv is common
that stillbirth is the uh most frequent
cause of death up until the age of 14
years in this country and in many
developed countries
and that about half of those cases of
stillbirth had no cause
and given that congenital cnv is known
to cause death in utero
we therefore looked for links and in
fact we found a
close association using pcr
as you all know pcr can
be associated with contamination so we
did these very carefully
but we also looked at a different
non-pcr based
method which was immunohistochemistry or
rihc
and in these unexplained cases of
stillbirth we found a significant rate
of infection that is congenital cnv
infection and so uh we went on to look
at
other causes because we thought we
should try and take a more
nuanced approach and see maybe infection
is more common than we expect
but in fact infection is really quite
rare in stillbirth
except with human cytomegalovirus that
is
congenital cmb is causing a number of
unexplained stillbirth cases
we repeated this prospectively and got a
lot lower number
but still a significant number of um
unexplained stillbirth is due to
congenital cmb
one of the things we did was in
collaboration with
pathologists to look at whether there
was something biologically plausible
because it's very important as you know
that if you do find an association
that's not just furious it's not just
something that occurs but it's not
actually causative and in fact
um these cases uh the infants who had
stillbirth
who had died uh who work in general cnb
positive
had a very high rate of what's called
fetal thrombotic vasculopathy
which is really put more simply a
a form of disease in the placenta
where the blood vessels clot and as you
might expect
that results in a placenta that can
become
inefficient at exchanging between the
mother and the
fetus and um is a plausible manner
in which cmv might be causing stillbirth
and so
we and others continue to look at this
these are um just to to show you some
real data and again this is now
published so
uh you can look it up but in essence if
you look at the placenta
of a baby who has sadly died from
congenital cmv that is who is still born
and died in utero
then you see a lot of inflammatory
changes you see a lot of inflammation
you see a lot of
th1 bias in the cytokines you see things
like
tnf alpha mcb1 which are inflammatory
cytokines
and you see this associated with
infection
with cmv and so not only do we have a
plausible
cause for some of these unexplained
stillbirths we also have a plausible
mechanism which is that
the virus stimulates some inflammation
that's via cytokines and i won't go in
detail but there are very good reasons
why cytokine based
inflammatory response would be logical
and
that we're actually seeing pathology as
a result of this which is
likely to cause the baby to have died so
what that gives us is some options and
it gives us some options for
how we might intervene in intervene
further down the track
before this occurs in order to prevent
stillbirth
so now on to a more i guess pragmatic
issue which is diagnosis
and as i mentioned before a little bit
of discussion about
um screening and and the logistics of
that potentially
one of the problems with cmv is that
around about half of um women who have
primary cnv during pregnancy have no
symptoms at all
so really maternal illness is not a good
way of thinking about
why you might be testing a newborn
i've shown you some day care center data
so if a mother is exposed either through
working in daycare or
having children in daycare and that
mother is known to be seronegative for
cnb
then she can undertake things that
reduce her risk but certainly
things like prematurity the presence of
a sexually transmitted
uh infection or high-risk behaviors um
younger mothers who have no antenatal
care
those kind of things are the the
flags if you like that make us think
about testing
a newborn for congenital infections
because those things are associated with
high risk of congenital infection
the other important point is of course
if a neonate presents with something and
we've talked about hearing loss
um and the fact that targeted what i
i call and others call targeted testing
rather than screening
but there are other things that make you
think that a neonate may have
had an infection in utero if they're
premature and prematurity occurs in
about
one in ten one in twelve infants
if they have a evidence of neurological
disease things like hydrocephalus or
microcephaly with other without other
explanations
if they're small if they're small for
gestational age or sga
and if they have other things that might
be associated with infection like
jaundice or hepatitis b and splenomegaly
then it's really important to think
about testing
those infants and often
in our setting we we see these infants
in collaboration with the pediatricians
because it's very important to look at
the pregnancy and and how that's
progressed
again often asked you know what
specimens should be taken and
um my response is usually as many as you
as you're willing to take
um but most importantly urine and throat
swab because
the sorts of infections we're looking
for particularly cmv
uh but also things like enteroviruses
and other infections
a throat swab and the urine is very
useful
it's also important to think about
the context and for example if
um neonatal serum is difficult to
obtain and of course antibody in
neonatal serum is often derived from the
mother
by uh transplacental transmission
it's also important potentially to take
the mother's serology
to see whether she has had an infection
and obviously in specific cases where
an infant may may have neurological
disease then
lumbar puncture and collection of
cerebrospinal fluid
uh if there are skin lesions or if
there's any other symptomatology then
appropriate specimens are taken
it's also important to look at the
placenta and do histopathology
and potentially to do testing using
molecular tests
for infection of the placenta
the sorts of tests we do today of course
are mainly based around nucleic acid
testing so
predominantly pcr although
there are other types of nucleic acid
tests used
uh and things like immunofluorescence
and virus culture are really
for the reference or research laboratory
we still do a lot of serology and
typically that's done with enzyme immuno
eia in high throughput well established
really nicely done commercial systems
there are issues around the utility of
igm
in a clinical setting and i'll talk
about that briefly
as a reference laboratory we here at
savage still do things like complexation
and
fluorescence although they're really in
the small number of difficult cases
where we can't sort them out using
enzyme immunoassay commercial assays and
electron microscopy again as you know
not done routinely but our research your
reference tool of course increasingly
other sorts of testing are available we
test the neonatal blood
screening card or dried blood spots for
things like cmv dna
and they can also be used to test from
remote and rural
settings we increasingly do multiplex
testing because of course
although congenital cmd is the most
common when
uh the question arises for example
in regards to high drops fatalis where
there's a baby with a lot of
fluid and the question of parvovirus b19
is raised
then the use of multiplexes where we
test for usually five or six at the
moment
um different viruses and and different
agents
including things like parvo b19 cmv
toxoplasma gondii perhaps
treponema for syphilis that kind of
testing will provide a very quick way of
ruling out things that
are extremely unlikely but you don't
want to miss because they're treatable
increasingly with our genotype our cnv
isolates using whole genome sequencing
that's become somewhere sort of halfway
between
the research and diagnostic laboratory
and in some centers it's freely
available it is in ours now
still some technical difficulties you do
need higher amounts of virus in order to
be able to
to obtain a successful whole genome
sequence although as we work further and
become more familiar with the technology
it will clearly become easier to test
even
at lower lower loads and we hope for
that in the next year or so
once a neonate is born as i mentioned
the neonatal gut screening card
can be used um if they're not seen soon
enough after birth
although if they are seen within the
first three weeks of life
um year and weekly you're an and saliva
uh although the correlation between them
is very close they're fairly easy to
collect
um our urine is collected by us in
nappies we're using cotton wool balls
we recently published this and it's
pretty straightforward
the problem being of course trying to
put a urine bag onto an unhappy
um struggling um crying
neonate is something that disturbs the
whole room
and becomes very difficult very
uncomfortable
not not pleasant for the baby
and really unpleasant for the parents
and so
anything that can make that easier in
testing neonates
is really a a great advance and so we
now collect urine and saliva routinely
as i mentioned
on any child failing their hearing
screening
we routinely request um testing of their
neonatal blood screening card and that's
relatively straightforward these days
so back to screening um at the moment
our guidelines
internationally do not recommend
screening of all pregnant
mothers for cnb using a cmv igg
i think that is a reasonable summation
of a difficult area
however if you look at the sorts of
criteria that were published now
over 20 years ago
if you if you wanted to look at
introducing a new screening test you had
to have detailed knowledge of the effect
on the
of the condition we have some knowledge
of that in congenital cmb so it gets a
tick
but it is very much dependent upon
timing the infection it's very difficult
during pregnancy
to really time infection because you
can't sample
the fetus easily except by amniocentesis
or cordocentesis
that's invasive it carries a risk for
the pregnancy it carries a risk for the
mother
it carries a risk for the fetus so um
the the amount of knowledge we will ever
gain is going to be
it's going to be difficult um do we have
highly accurate and specific tests
we certainly do in seeing the igg
serology so we can certainly tell
mothers whether they're immune
that is they have seen the igg or not
and therefore whether they're
at risk of primary infection the
difficulties are around igm
and the fact that a number of mothers
are igm positive and yet have had
uh remote infections many years before
but they probably do have truly
persisting igm
we don't think this is cross reactivity
and this can be sorted out using
uh cmvi gg ability so it is possible to
sort it out
and it is possible to not
not have something that's confusing but
it does require resources and it does
require people to be
available in order to test for um
test for this um is it a significant
health problem well i hope i've
convinced you
that is that there's no doubt that this
is the infectious and the
problem with congenital infections and
going forward
are any actions on the basis of results
ethically acceptable
this is increasingly becoming sorted out
it's difficult
it's um not something that we can
um it's something that changes with time
it's not definitive and
um but uh the uncertainty of diagnosis
particularly with other things like igm
a lot of that's been reduced with newer
tests and a lot of that's been improved
with things like
ability and one thing that we didn't
have until the last few years
were the economic implications is this
cost saving does this improve
the overall um
you know economic good of the
population can you justify this and
i i think i'd like to think that we can
justify
the um this on the basis of improving
health
without any doubt um can we justify it
economically well soren gand published a
paper in 2016
from north america in canada
and that clearly showed economic benefit
williams published a paper around the
same time
again in the uk and again showed
economic benefits so
really we're coming to the point where
we need to discuss this again
in a group of international experts and
talk further about screening
if you look at current screening it's
it's quite
um it's quite interesting because of
course things like syphilis and group b
streptococcus we can do something about
we can use antibiotics
things like rubella we still screen and
yet as i mentioned
because of vaccination uh it's a
uh it's a it's a vanishingly rare
disease and
these are numbers from australia um
there were 51 cases of rubella
between the 10 years between 2001 and
2011
and there were three cases over that
time of congenital
rubella syndrome so it's important to
sort out there there need to be cases
rubella before you can get cases of
congenital belly syndrome
and really one every three years is a
tiny number and that's great
it's fantastic benefit of vaccination
the question then arises whether we
still need to do screening
and and reasonably we still do although
of course with cost-benefit discussions
it's important to look at what we do
not only going forward but what we've
done in the past
if we did screen antenatally we would
find at risk and low-risk women
it would be definitive for whether they
were sero-negative or sero-positive as i
mentioned
much harder if we did igm because of the
issues around persisting igm
we do know that interventions such as
hand washing
and gloves reduce the transmission rate
we don't have a great vaccine there was
one the trial for which
was published by bob pass now
some time ago 10 years and it only
showed about a
50 efficacy um
and we do know that targeted screening
for hearing loss works
uh well somewhere between five to ten
percent of uh
of affected neonates being found as i
mentioned we published this but there's
been lots of other publications from
people globally
um and i guess one thing is
you've got to look at the downsides
antidotal screening will miss women who
are seropositive but who reactivate and
that's an important number
of women who track who are transmitting
many women during pregnancy reactivate
cmv a small proportion of them transmit
to the baby and
those babies can be as severely affected
as with primary infection
but also of course some infants who have
congenital cmv
don't have hearing loss at birth but by
the age of
five years they will have
had hearing loss and so that's around
about
um half two-thirds of those who
eventually have hearing loss during
congenital
congenital cmb so it's really important
that if we do
look at screening of mothers for example
that we think about what the downsides
can be
so the reality is um
if you have adequate follow-up screening
works
there's a reasons to do something and um
it's it's obvious that's that whether we
screen or not testing an individual
mother is important
and you need to think about the
individual
person and there is some
now health economic evidence for
population screening and what we now
need is that to be done in a population
and for it to be measured properly
because the papers that i mentioned from
gantt and the one from williams are
really
theoretical based around modeling and
they clearly show
an economic benefit but ideally what we
need to do is now do that in the
population
again from the paper by mike cannon
these are u.s
figures and this looked at if we
screened
all neonates and this is in the us where
there's
about four million four and a half
million live births
and if we just went through a sort of
decision tree
and said well if we screened or neonates
how much hearing loss would we
prevent and down the bottom of this
slide is where i'd like you to focus
there's good evidence and fair evidence
that would probably
improve the lives of around about
about a thousand babies every year in
the us
and that would be because we'd be
picking up asymptomatic infections would
be picking up
a number of children who would not
necessarily be diagnosed otherwise
if you do the same thing with cognitive
deficits so with
neurological deficits due to congenital
cmv
you don't get as strong evidence but
you do get fair evidence for a
population of about
one to one half thousand so this was
really aimed at sort of modeling
if we screened would what what do we
think the benefit would be
and there's no doubt that there would be
some so it's really very much watch this
space i think over the next
one to five years and as we make
decisions about
you know screening and as we think about
policy
and we think about testing and as our
testing and other algorithms become more
developed my view is that there will be
a number of countries going forward
looking at
um universal neonatal screening and
considering
universal maternal screening for cmv
of course even though we try for many
years there are just some things we
can't get people to do
so what about mother to child
transmission i mentioned this before and
i'd just like to show you a little bit
of
research because i think it's important
in considering
our interventions which will be my final
set of discussion
um because if you don't understand
what's happening then how are you going
to intervene properly
i mentioned that cmv is transmitted
vertically
mainly through the uh via the placenta
so transplacental transmission
um postnatal transmission can occur by
breast milk
and certainly um cmv is transmittable by
breast milk
along in fact with antibodies that are
present
but most most the vast majority of
congenital cmv is due to transplacental
transmission
and what that means is that somehow from
the maternal
circulation on the left of the slide
virus is able to get across
the uh sensitive trophoblast and
trophoblast layer
and get into the blood the blood vessels
that then
supply blood to the fetus and they're
the ones shown here in the middle of the
villas that that
prominent thing sticking out from the
right to the left
and what cmv does is it disrupts these
layers clearly the placenta works very
well to stop infection from getting
across to the
mother the reality is that
by causing disruption to the sensitive
trophoblasts
cmv can get across more easily there are
specific
markers but unfortunately as part of
that
cmv not only infects the fetus but
investor placenta
and causes damage to the center and
number two here shows reduced
cytotrophic blast invasion
which are a major major problem of
disease
of causing disease rather because
shallow placentation really results in
reduced gas and nutrient supply to the
placenta and hence to the fetus
and what that means is that the fetus
effectively becomes starved
now unfortunately that's the cause of a
lot of the problems that um arise
in that that infant subsequently
cytotrophic blast and placenta are very
interesting organ i'm not going to talk
about that in any detail except
that cytotrophic lasso cells i showed
you on the surface
do have cell receptors for cmv um
they do change as the um as the
they mature so as placenta matures they
go from different
cell sort of types and different protein
markers and as they do that
unfortunately they become susceptible to
cmv
infection the
um the placenta as i mentioned a
fascinating organ
one of our research interests and this
basically shows
uh what we and others do where we take
the placenta
um from a consenting mother
we we in in
cell culture grow it over a period of
time and then we're able to infect it
and we can use that placenta
in order to understand better how cmv
affects the placenta and affects the
fetus this is just the model we use very
quickly
we infect a lower layer those little
stars are
a virus coming up to infect the placenta
layer which is floating on a
nutrient bed we then
look at what happens with the infection
of that placenta in this case we look at
cytokine expression
what that means is that we can
understand
what cmv infection is doing to the real
placenta not just to
to isolated or animal placenta but to
the human placenta
and i won't go through in detail but um
if you just look
this is one of our experiments from a
while ago the red
here is cnv identified and this is a
placenta which has been infected with
cmv and then we've measured
uh what it's done to the cytokines and
of course this is a fantastic model
uh where we can examine the what the
effects of
antivirus are on cnb infection so a
little bit about prevention
a little bit about treatments and a
little bit of research this is a sad
phrase that
um uh one of uh a woman who
and her partner who consulted me um
and and really this is why we are so
keen on prevention because
the evidence is less than one in ten in
many populations less than five
parents have ever heard of cmv or
congenital cmv
don't do anything about it and the first
time they hear about it is when they
have an affected baby
or evidence on ultrasound of an
effective fetus
and really at that point the
opportunities prevention have completely
gone
so again back to our international
recommendations
published three years ago all pregnant
women should be provided information on
congenital cnb
infection this is just a no-brainer this
is just the way it should be
and it's important that this is provided
in a
cautious in a well-informed uh manner
that they're allowed follow-up
um that they are allowed um you know the
opportunity to digest it
but really the sorts of things we're
talking about
shown in the cartoon at the top that
mothers can do to prevent
transmission things like washing your
hands not sharing food
kiss on the forehead not on the lips
wear gloves when you're changing nappies
those things reduce transmission from
mother to baby
by about 40 percent so almost
one in two cases of congenital cmv
infection
could simply be prevented by mothers
knowing about it
mothers doing something about it and
just reducing their risk of transmission
doesn't cost anything not terribly
inconvenient
we did some work a while ago and looked
at the messages around congenital cmv
prevention
and mothers fathers find this very
acceptable
they don't find it threatening so long
as they're provided with
appropriate information so long as
they're provided with the opportunity to
discuss it
then 99 of women want more information
and that's a pretty good number
we do know that education results in
improvements in their behavior amanda
lazaro published that in 2019
and we do know that this has a direct
result
on how many women sarah convert and
become infected and
maria graceri revello in italy published
that five years ago
so really the message is clear tell
parents about congenital cmv
they don't get frightened they
don't have to have a high education
level to understand
hand washing lack of sharing of foods
kiss on the forehead not on the lips
it's not complicated
and this reduces congenital cmb and it
reduces transmission
by up to half
as i mentioned not many parents know
about
cmv but interestingly only one in ten
health professionals
in australia and we believe it's similar
internationally and other developed
in other developed countries only one in
ten health care professionals when we
did this survey were talking with
their pregnant women about cmb
all the times we talk about rubella all
the times we talk about toxo
all the times we talk about listeria are
important this is one more thing
but it's the most important of all of
those
so what do we do about it as i mentioned
we and others are doing lots
approaching midwives working on
structured educational programs
our primary care physicians doing
webinars
the college of general practitioners
here in australia
within associated webinars and also
linking up with in-hospital services to
provide information
and things like social media campaigns
as you know have enormous reach
things like advertisements on google
things like providing internet access
you know accessible facebook twitter
feeds
uh going on television and saying
congenital cmvs
important and people are doing this
everywhere in around the world and these
are just examples of what's been done in
australia because that's where i
practice
but these get enormous reach and
maybe you're making a difference there's
a there's a sort of qualitative
viewing that i'm getting in my clinics
and stuff that people are a bit better
educated than they were
internationally congenital cmv has been
added to the new
who earth defects surveillance toolkit
which is fantastic
because we've largely talked about
developed countries because that's where
i practice and that's where my work is
however developing countries have a
significantly higher rate of congenital
cmv
because of reactivation and transmission
and so international efforts like this
are critical
to to getting large numbers of people
globally aware
congenital cmv this is a book where
um which is a sort of you know um
common language uh how to what it's like
to be pregnant and what you need to look
out for and cmb's
been included in this year's edition um
there's e-learning modules the benefit
of those of course is they're free
they're created and then they're
globally available
and things like cmv awareness
get a bit overshadowed as you might
expect by the current um
pandemic and issues but they still go on
and
they still continue and people who are
engaged with these have
been universally
praising them as a way of getting their
education up but also getting their
parents up
and the parents that they see and
getting their understanding and
education better
so a little bit about therapies in
essence there's no
great therapy at the moment during
pregnancy and that's why we need more
research
again this is a review which showed
limited evidence for intravenous
immunoglobulin
it looked at vaccine the initial vaccine
trial which again as i mentioned showed
50
efficacy it's not all gloom and doom
there are further studies looking at
things like ballet cyclovir these are
probably
treatments like immunoglobulin that
during pregnancy reduced the risk of
transmission
by a very small amount and in talking to
patients i use the term experimental
treatments
however what they do provide is a launch
pad for our next
group of um of antivirals
we and others are interested in small
interfering rnas
and this this simply shows some
published data uh
it essentially shows that srnas do
inhibit cmv
they inhibit the amount of cmv they
inhibit
mother-to-child transmission in our
placental model
and a lot of people are doing very
sophisticated work on this clearly
there are also one new antivirals
based around things like and marijuana
termovir which are
now licensed for use in transplantation
um
but those antivirals tend to be much
less toxic and so it will be important
to look at those in
pregnancy and certainly uh having phase
three trials where
we can see them uh it's also important
to continue to develop
novel and new antivirals this these are
some that we
work on but again there are many that um
people work on internationally
these quinasalins are very effective in
reducing
infection but they are toxic and so
that's what i mean others are looking at
and finally i mentioned earlier on about
the placenta being damaged
it's really important that we
think about the fetus as being dependent
upon the percentage and we think about
the placenta and the fetus as a single
unit if you like
so there's no there's no point in just
stopping
infection and if the percentage is so
damaged by cytokines for example
that the baby is not going to be um
receiving nutrition and therefore the
baby is dying because of that
so really important that we think about
that
dirks or a human protein that are from
uh presenting placenta and um we've
looked at these essential
models and if you actually inhibit this
particular protein which is upregulated
by cnb so
been seen being flexible center the
amount of dirt goes up
um if you stop that from happening then
what we see in fact is that
you also stop infection so it's a um
it's a really good potential target and
if there are many of these or there are
several of them
but there's enough that we have um the
opportunity
to look at these inhibitors as potential
treatments and
go going forward that we can have great
hope that
with congenital cmv not only will
vaccines be important
but also treatments will be uh hopefully
available
this is more a five to ten year timeline
but that's what research is about it's
looking to the future and
taking your best shot now and doing your
best work and
finding something that potentially will
work in the
future the other thing of course is some
is exchange of information
something that's changed so completely
this year that it's hard to imagine that
last year we used to go to international
conferences
but really that continuing international
global exchange is absolutely critical
so just a summary cmv prevention
is proven to reduce infections so i
think there's two things and i like this
from dr seuss thing one and thing
two um the reality is the first thing is
we can do something now
we can absolutely do things like inform
mothers
informed fathers get health care workers
better informed
provide information online about cmv
prevention
hand washing don't kiss on the lips
don't share food
don't go sleep a lot of don'ts but
what it does is makes the risk of cmv
lower
and what it does is reduces the number
of babies dying and severely affected
from
cmb every year and we know this and we
know this now so we should be doing it
and we should be doing it to the utmost
of our ability
as clinicians uh for the the parents
that we're seeing
and it doesn't cost anything it's really
minimal cost
the other thing one that we can do now
is targeted testing so
testing of infants who fail
sensorineural hearing screening loss
and considering more broadly uh
screening
tests for all neonates and for
all mothers and considering it in a um
a sensible evidence-based way because
we've got enough much more evidence
the second thing we need to do is really
to continue to
understand and develop new treatments
and develop
new vaccines and there's plenty of these
coming along and there's some really
great vaccine work of course being done
currently
with the pandemic and some of that will
actually transmit into seeing the
vaccines so research is critical um
it's important to understand the the
fetus as
a as an interacting person or for
interacting
uh part that um interacts with the
placenta and with the mother and that
think about what's happening at a
at a global level think about uh how we
can intervene
and um improve those outcomes for the
fetus
not only now but in going forward in the
future
so finally we're about at the end
i'd like to acknowledge the group that i
work with which is the top left we also
grew worked with a group of man from
marshall who's based in
london in germany uh of course in these
days we
work at a distance and we work
with video and that works very well we
don't see as much of each other directly
or as much of our students but these the
people who've done the work
these are the people who are doing
research but also a number of people in
public health who are
introducing and changing policy as we go
and finally
i really like to thank the parents uh
this is a group of people who
uh with congenital cmb suffer with their
children
and who with things like the um
non-government organizations general cmp
association australia
uh the cerebral palsy alliance there are
similar
um ngos all around the world and these
are people who suffered because
their children have congenital cmv and
they stand with them
and it's their support that really keeps
us going
so thank you very very much for
attention and
we'll draw to a close